[Music]
please don't get involved
what's poppin fam it is monday morning
what is happening how's everybody doing
how was your weekend
for those parents out there schools are
uh starting back up kiddo's going back
to school kiddo started today
first day of first grade holler holler
first day of first grade do you remember
your first day of first grade nope me
neither nope
i remember
some things of kindergarten like first
aid kindergarten remember a little bit
can i remember that like these blow up
uh
alphabet yeah i remember certain parts
but other than that no
no not at all uh fresh off the plane
from chicago shout out to chicago
went out there
for the tough mudder i've done my fourth
tough mudder third this year
went out there
to
do a tough mudder in chicago now when i
say chicago it's right outside chicago
now i say right outside chicago i mean
about two hours outside chicago hour and
a half
you know you can't
market it as that you know small suburbs
so they say chicago and hopefully
everybody figures it out and drives all
the way the hell out there
now uh going into this
i mean me and mark
mark carly ran it with me he runs all of
them with me going into we do some
training um i would say i did the least
amount of training for this one just
because of scheduling and all that stuff
so i was so nervous to do it the night
before we're with the the tough mudder
and rain team and uh one of the tough
mudder oh the tough mudder guys came to
my comedy show at the laugh factor
chicago shout out to the laugh factory
chicago
so they go um there and um
he uh
the the guy goes yeah this this that's
not from that's from uh
san diego yeah that would be yeah that's
that's the squad there so they come to
the left factory chicago and the tough
mudder guy goes yeah you know we
this is in the top
five this ranked number three is
toughest course so have fun tomorrow i'm
like oh say last year you've been
training like oh absolutely
not like i should but uh yeah so they
came to the comedy show we did two shows
one one at 7 31 9 30. it's always weird
because
it'd be like coming to the laugh factory
i'm sure for a chicago comic coming the
laugh actor here
comedy store here improv here that's
like their home club so it's all like
you know the local comics i was just
popping up doing spots
so it's so you know it's always a it's
not my show serious you know watch your
p's and cubes it was a fun time though
some monster comics out there in chicago
man the whole lineup was some monsters
uh it was fun though it was a lot of fun
but the tough mudder was so much fun man
best one we've done
even though they said it's gonna be one
of the toughest by far one the best i
think is the train
because it's all like
mud you go through rivers like you
literally gotta swim through a river uh
this dude if you go back gin on the
video so this is the electric thing i
absolutely hate it you get shocked here
to finish the race i absolutely hate it
i try to get out of it every year
so the guy next to me looks like you
know he should be in braveheart
he was like because i was asking mark i
was like man what do you think is the
best route and he's like i go here so
we're going back and forth and before
that he's like are you just going to
stand there man let's finish this thing
i'm like didn't you go dude
and so he's like i'll go and he gets all
crunk watch him
yeah so he passes out and then pops back
up the thing that they don't show you is
in that cord is uh a big chunk of his
beard
he got messed up people got you know
people got tore up a lot of people got
tore up man a lot of people i mean some
girl broke her leg she fell off the top
of like the monkey bars thing and just
snapped her leg
um but we ran it with the buttery bros
the [ __ ] the buttery bros were i mean
they make it so much fun man
yeah this was a wet one
it was fun though man the buddy bros
they can just go for days they do like
marathons and [ __ ] yeah they look like
they're
very very in shape in super shape i'll
see them in salt lake city when i do
wise guys i think i'm there in october
november i forget but that's their home
base i don't think it's up yet is it oh
it is october
there it is october 20th the 22nd
buddy bros will be there cool um you
have so much fun so much fun man
shout out to chicago there's some big uh
fights over the weekend um
one championship's trying to take over
america and they they came out with
their best foot forward and they did a
pretty damn good job as far as
entertainment value and production they
are damn good it was a really really
good card fun card
um they did it you know 7 p.m pacific
time so it's like the
main time to do it to draw the american
audience because usually i stay up i
mean
i think it's [ __ ] thursday in
singapore when they do it you know it's
always strange to keep up with so we
just see highlights out here unless
you're just a savage and you know you
watch it at three in the morning
something like that but they had a
rematch with mighty mouse and marias
and if you remember uh mariah's beat
mighty mouse i think like 16 months ago
about 16 months ago rough ko too rough
ko so this was the big rematch um
you know i don't know why
anyone including myself doubted mighty
mouse he's never lost a rematch he's
also never been ko'd
so first time he fights uh adriano
mariah he gets ko'd bat with that knee
against the fence
and this fight you know
part of the issue is is moriah's is just
so much bigger way bigger i mean i know
they do the the weight thing there and
the the it's a different protocol than
the ufc
i just i don't get how this guy makes
the way i don't know exactly even when
rich franco is on food truck which
dropped last week with angela lee the
champ champ who's soon to be champ champ
um he's explaining the weight cut and
you're like
it sounds right but then
i mean walking away after i ate uh
freaking you know all the egg whites
stones like hey what's the weight
cutting protocol in one championship i'm
like i don't know
you know like they i know they can't do
extreme cuts like the ufc does like they
gotta stay within a certain weight
i just
there has to be some advance insane
advantage because if mariah's in the ufc
he ain't fighting at that weight class
there's no way he's enormous dude
so mighty mouse had to go to the drawing
board and come up with a different game
plan and he talks a little bit about it
where his game plan was to to wear him
out apply pressure go forward expecting
to eat shots but eventually wearing them
out which is nuts to do against a guy
this much bigger
now
technique wise you know there's a reason
why
there's an argument mighty mouse is the
best to ever do it because technical
you're not going to find anyone better
as far as mixed martial arts goes as far
as striking
uh fundamentals
grappling wrestling putting it all
together there's never been anybody
better than dj doing that so um he has
that advantage even though he's under
size and to be honest you know
when this fight started
you know it looked like it was going to
go morice's way a little bit there did
you watch it yeah yeah it looked like
you know marissa was lighting him up you
know he
dj spent a lot of time on his back and
then you know once uh maurice even
landed a big head kick that wobbled him
you know so you're like oh my god but it
was all part of the plan you know and dj
kept lighting up finding that left hand
the liver shot and really this just
shows you the experience of dj
you know he was just weathering the
storm weather and storm and was and it
worked because mariah got tired rice got
tired and then he got ko bad
you have to highlight here boom
very similar the way dj got k.o
[Applause]
he doesn't wait for the ref to jump in
he knew professional
shout out to dj man i wonder what they
do because you know two knockouts so
mariah's that's his first time ever
being ko'd
and then the 16 months ago that was the
first time ever dj got ko so they've
both been their first kos
you know for each other so obviously you
got to run that back but i wonder what
they do
i wonder what they do the whole card was
entertaining man all right my boy liam
harrison dude that clip right here is
insane
so yeah knocked out
a rough one
and he runs off too
boom
god dawg insane
i mean that cannot feel good
filthy
the production values just um
it's it's you know there's a lot of uh
uh pride um flavor in there you know
they do have some of the pride staff
work with them so they make sense
the whole presentation they're bringing
down the belt stuff like that
you know i know some people like oh they
you know they're copying pride they're
copying this organization the captain
you see with this
it is their own thing it's it's a collab
it's a mix of their own thing that you
know is
has been tradition or in the past you
know they're doing the thing production
is insane though i told you guys those
wildcats are a different level
and i i think uh uh i was texting uh
josh thompson you're saying he had some
issues with the stream i didn't have any
issues
at all it's amazon amazon prime i have
no issues
at all uh my boy marcus amita boucha got
it done baby
was he 3-0 now 4-0 now all submissions
heel hook filthy
he's such a nice guy too those
heavyweights kicked the main card off
jesus christ they were scrapping
yeah four
yeah bushes is gonna be a problem
cheshire is gonna be a big problem man
you know
we'll see how go you know again he's 4-0
he and he has done all his fights at one
championship so he you know he is in the
big league so
i i assume they start toss them some
tougher opponents
[ __ ] see how he does with like uh
you know i'm trying to think on the
roster who would be a guy with a
wrestling background especially like a
russian devastating background
can't take him down really and he has
you know pretty good striking better
than the bushes you can see how bushes
tries to navigate that land you know
but he has all the makings of world
champion man such a good dude too you
know those heavyweights amir ali barky
and mario cirelli they were slaying it
there's just a good card
let's take a little break from me just
chatting your air off about fighting few
tour dates coming up for you la this
wednesday one show only 8 pm david spade
michael rapport myself some other
monsters a very special guest once your
only shop and friends of hollywood
improv this wednesday at 8 pm one show
only then the real tour kicks off next
week next thursday friday saturday i'm
in appleton wisconsin appleton wisconsin
almost sold out september 8th through
the 10th get your tickets right now then
ontario california ontario improv one of
my favorite clubs september 15th to the
17th then i end september in boston one
of my favorite places i named my son
boston because of it boston is september
29th through october 1st at laugh boston
come get you some boston tickets at
thickboy.com
bros fancy football draft season is
right around the corner all right cd
lamb is good but have you seen these
nuts it's time to get your snake looking
right for this snake draft with the
sponsor of today's show we talking about
manscape the leader in below the waist
grooming have created an undefeated and
dare i say championship lineup with the
performance package 4.0 join the 6
million bros worldwide who trust
manscape and get ready for kickoff by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with code shob20 if you
groom below the waist the performance
package 4.0 is perfect for you legend
has it this roster has won the league
for the last six years inside the
performance package 4.0 you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0
oh sorry i'm getting crunk weed whacker
ear nose hair trimmer the crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance box of briefs and a travel
bag all right tom brady didn't come out
of retirement for you to have hairy nuts
we gotcha man so all you got to do if
you want all that stuff especially the
lawnmower 4.0 my favorite thing ever get
20 off and free shipping with coach
shop20 at manscape.com that's twimp soft
and free shipping with the code
at manscape.com it's time to put the pp
back in the ppr get a grip on your
pigskin this season with manscape oh
it's my favorite time of the year and
i'm not talking about the holiday season
i'm talking about football is back baby
yes the new season's about to begin
that afc west is popping all four teams
are damn good you got the la chargers
you got the chiefs you got the raiders
and my denver broncos with russell with
wilson baby get ready for the nfl week
one action with draftking sportsbook the
official sporting better betting partner
of the nfl to celebrate the return of
football draftkings has given new
customers that can't miss offer bet just
five dollars on any football game and
get 200 and free bets instantly you want
more action for opening night cool
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion get up
seven you win bet on any nfl team of
your choice and if your team leads by
seven points at any point during the
game you get paid instantly even if your
team loses as long as some point in the
game they're up by seven how could you
not like that draftking's a safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdraw whenever you want download
draftking sportsbook app right now use
the promo code shop show sch aub show to
get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game that's coach's
shop show only a draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl minimum age and lgbt restrictions
apply see show notes for details see you
next page for directions of disclaimer
download draftking sportsbook promo code
shop show and then angelese brother one
yeah the day before a little stud
christmas rematch that whole family
jesus christ i know you talked about
them last week [ __ ] man
oh i'm just studs here's a little clip
of them
there's some reclaiming that that'll
yeah
[Music]
oof
those knees are gnarly right yeah
the torque you can
just the torque you can get behind the
knees man
oh drops and then the knees here
yeah it's filthy
yeah i do i i really wish the ufc would
allow this
especially with the takeover of these
russians and dagestanians and chechnyans
like you want more finishes that's
that's how you get that's true dude
that's like a real fight yeah yeah
brutal
shout out to christian lee man
yeah fun card man really fun card you
have another uh good card this weekend
uh especially for a fight night the
international fight nights are i mean
they see it easy i'm sure that they they
do the fight nights this first time
they're in france right so
i assume they do the fight nights like
this because the time like it's a it's a
noon yeah 12 p.m five times yeah pacific
time so
a pay-per-view would definitely take a
hit there then also
ufc's smart obviously they're smart as
[ __ ] but um
you know this is the this saturday's the
kickoff of big time college football
like it kicks off with notre dame ohio
state
listen i love fighting love fight love
it never miss it
but you're out your goddamn mind you
think i would it now if it's like a
packed fight card
all right now you got my attention i
have to go two tvs on it split screen
but you'd have to take a special card to
get me to
take my eyes off of ohio state notre
dame opening weekend man
like i love college football love love
college football and pro but prefer
college football can't wait
stoked
notre dame has that new coach young i
think he's 35
you know and he's half
korean and black
nice yes
kids are super [ __ ] cute yeah he's a
new coach young too coach the kids love
them can't help but root for that guy
yeah
good-looking and and he played at ohio
state oh nice yeah coach freeman he
played at ohio state first game head
coach notre dame playing at ohio state
big deal man really big deal yeah i i
think i think his mom's korean or he
might be um
you see what he is she's like super
asian like
because the dad was in uh the military
went over there and they you know met
there
dude his mother's name is my brother's
name that's yeah korean yeah south
korean chong
yeah
dude so is notre dame your favorite team
now i'm starting to like the korean head
coach starting to grow on me name
another one
yeah me neither
there's uh chang or chung who's the
offense coordinator for usc when they
had like reggie bush matt leinhardt and
they went to the pros
[Music]
i know there's like half black half
korean people in nfl the film at least
there's a few yeah pittsburgh steelers
guy
i forgot his name
he was like a star oh heinz ward yeah
heinz ward he's half korean too
there's like a really good looking dude
that's half korean half black that gwen
that was just vietnamese yeah yeah i'm
just telling him
i know in the nfl like dude
tough gig yeah
he was fat too man like as a kid he was
like fat
and then even as he was a bit like big
as a player
you know
and now he's in shape yeah 36
2 years old and being a hat the head
coach of notre dame no pressure papa
yeah
cool yeah he ran he rised fast too man
yeah can't help but root for that guy
now you have to group for him jim like i
said yeah my new favorite name is
our same uh first name as your brother
yup his mom which is interesting yeah
mm-hmm
yeah so you got ufc fight night uh
paris
first time ufc's in bears
you know they're missing one of the
biggest french guys
in france i mean he's african french-ish
right speaks french francis singano
um he will not be on this card for a
variety of reasons so you bring in the
second best guy he got cyril gone who's
all french
sierra gone versus my boy taitu avasa
uh we actually have thai's uh
chewie here chewie vasa
should we is it called a chewy bun
but here's the thing listen
tied to avasa is famous in the ufc for
doing shoes
the shoei really starved my boy uh
daniel ricardo for f1 he's only made it
super famous because he'd do it after
races
i thought you could talk smack on the
shipping time i thought you're gonna go
oh shipping time disaster though i mean
this thing came home it's changed four
months later and it's
the size i mean i wore that this is a
tiny shoe let's get a for the thicker
shoe dude you know
it's like a weird like
running cross-country shoe you know like
like come on ty's a thick dude man have
a thick ass shoe this should be a
[ __ ] blontiago chunky shoe
you know
i would do a shoe i don't know how to
set it up who knows how to set it up
i've never done it i don't know how to
do one
really all right so mark's gonna help
out here is he can get me all wet should
we do a shoei in hopes tie two of us
wins here's the thing ty's probably a
plus 500 or something
technical wise cyril gone there's a
reason why he's such a huge favorite
this is a the worst matchup for taito
vasa but taitovasa
does have
the one knockout punch power that
sirogon does not have so if you are a
fan of tai which i am and i'm definitely
rooting for him for this fight because
sir gun although i appreciate his
technique and his body um
he's not the most exciting heavyweight
we have on the roster tied to avasa
would it be such because ty wins this
he's going sizzler
so yeah dude at heavyweight a minus 540
is nuts
and then tie two of us is plus 420 you
just got to hope tai two of us that
lands
a big punch you know
tai chuvasa's biggest one would be derek
lewis but that was kind of a pick em
right like whoever lands first he land
that elbow that [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh the black beast up
you know but outside that he you know he
hasn't beat a lot of
upper echelon guys
you know
so before that you know he beat uh to be
so he was on a three fight losing streak
he lost a uh dos santos
uh
that ivanov fight was not great uh
sergio beat him
yet you know his best win is definitely
derek lewis before that sakai
greg hardy you know
uh but look at just ko ko ko ko ko he's
fun man it'd be so fun if you got a
title shot
we need him to win this fight you gotta
hope he lands that
that hail mary lands the bomb uh much
easier said than done because cyril gone
has fought
dudes who have
dynamite in their hands like
um [ __ ] rosenstroke like he's fought
some guys man he's
his footwork he's he's by far the most
athletic heavyweight if you've seen him
on instagram duncan basketballs and [ __ ]
like he's a freak man
so just if all you have is that big
right hand it's gonna be tough
time has to make this
ugly we need a phone booth fight for for
ty he needs to make it ugly get in there
hopefully land some of those elbows he
landed on derrick lewis but you know
derek loses sarah gone are far cry from
each other as far as technical wise
should we do a shoe in honor of ty
getting it done go for it all right
let's try it good luck ty this for you
buddy listen i'm not great at
chugging and stuff like that i've
actually have a small throat despite the
rumors that's great
ready here we go this is for thai
against cyril gone
oh [ __ ]
oh
you should get buzzed real quick now
never mind a little buzz
oh
well that thing fires out of there yep
that thing works
jesus christ
you're gonna be burping a lot too i
think oh nah man
we'll see
well hopefully that brings good luck to
ty
don't be mad at that chugging ability
either boys that's pretty fast thank you
yeah
we couldn't bear with that
sapara sapara japanese
hmm
[ __ ] well
could have done em all since but that's
not even australian you know that
molson's out of america
it but it they say you know or what's
what's the there's one bear
faster fosters yeah fosters fosters yeah
molson's cores shout of course uh
molson's is canadian but fosters
pretends they're like the outback
steakhouse
so this is founded in australia right
but i'm pretty sure it's uh made here
yep victoria about two american brothers
who killed a brewery last year later
foster was found melbourne victoria by
two american brothers
there you go
the more you know
it's not like it says it's not an
australian beer australian for lager it
may claim to be but
are brewed in manchester oh it's english
interesting wow
boy i'm dizzy
yep that's what happens when you're
drunk shout out to ty man listen i think
he eventually gets it done in like the
second round
first
even the third listing cardio's not on
our side either here the first round
it's going to be [ __ ] tough to hit
shell gun with that footwork
second round
you know and cereal doesn't care
bourne fight cool man as long as he's
winning again that's why i'm
i don't know sarah almost a great guy i
root for tattoo of us it's a great story
um cyril gone in every facet of mixed
mushrooms is better
but uh he doesn't have the knockout
power that ty possesses so if you're
tied to a boss fan you gotta hope sir
gone takes his [ __ ] eye off the
clock for a second and then gets rocked
other than that it's been a tough night
for taito vasa but i'll take tai two of
us all day and the combat event is
fantastic got robert whittaker marvin
vittori really especially since robert
whitaker went to middleweight these guys
have um
the same issue where
either one could be champ but they have
a man in front of him named israel
adesanya stylebender who beat both of
them
now vettori had a better outing
out of
the two of them
speaking of um
robert whittaker and victoria but dory
had a better showing against izzy the
first time they fought which was
a hot second ago in 2018 because he lost
split decision
if you remember in glendale arizona but
then in the rematch you know it wasn't
much of a fight the rematch is he just
got it done and beat him um but
you know i will say the one thing about
marm vittori love vittori is his work
ethic and he always adapts and just
makes changes he's constantly getting
better so
um again for vettori tough fight for him
against widow command which gives a
powerful dude
and um again the only guy that both of
them have lost in the middleweight
division is a man named israel adesanya
israel is not there either one of them
could be champion
already
whitaker would have he's been champion
whitaker would you know probably
dominate the division but it could be a
massive start isn't for izzy but he's
there beat both of them
four times between the both of them so
um
you know it's kind of like all right you
win this one you get a third chance that
is he you know for izzy it's like how do
you get up for it you know
i assume victoria's a bit of an underdog
is that right jen
um
plus 195 whitaker two
230.
and whitaker's one of my favorite
fighters but again i love marvin tori he
does make changes
you the only thing is you know people
forget whitter can wrestle his ass off
people forget y'all must have forgot
like whittaker king can [ __ ] wrestle
he's explosive he's the knockout power
victoria again similar to tai tuvasa
he's gonna have to make it ugly man
he's gonna have to make it really ugly
there's a reason he's a plus one ninety
five
but i'll take victorian tie two of
awesome that'd be fun but i i whitaker's
one of my favorite fighters
the card's good though the whole card is
good uh i think the most entertaining
fight listen
vittori and
whitaker and cyril gone and tai tovasi
could be very boring fights if
ty wins that fight super exciting if he
loses you're getting five rounds of
snoozefest sargon you know he'll just
sit back pick him apart doesn't really
go for the the kill there for robert
whittaker if marv tory you know is
feeling himself that night feeling
froggy and jumps into some rubber
whitaker will put your lights out that's
a good fight that's a fun fight and then
my favorite fight in the car um one of
my favorites nasrat is a [ __ ] savage
at lightweight i always love to see him
fight in romans of savage as well
you know just and there's a they you
know even though they're not technically
french they speak french so i'm sure
we're bringing a lot of french on the
mic i took four years in high school so
if you guys need a translator holler if
you guys are watching it holler
but it's a good card overall especially
for a fight night they're stacking these
fight nights they're also competing
against you know opening day of college
football so like the big weekend i'm
sure there's a thursday night game
there's some [ __ ] games this
previous weekend but those don't count
really this is the big boy
but yeah whole card is good man
what else you got jen
all right let's take a look here
well this is i don't know if you care
about this at all but ksi fought over
the weekend i got it yeah i guess about
two different dudes same night in the
same night yeah knocked the first guy
out named swarms his name swarm swarms i
think he's a rapper hell yeah and the
other fight was just embarrassing he's
got some guy named pineda who's a boxer
but he was just embarrassing why why
embarrassing he would actually complain
like a body shot to the ref so in case i
would hit him with that shock to him
yeah the body shot to the body and then
he would look at the ref and go like
what
like you're not supposed to hit the body
and then he kept saying like back of the
head it was embarrassing god ksi is
massive i don't realize how
ksi is a good dude too he was he went on
flagrant with schultz
i take schultz i'm like he seems like a
really good dude man
it was on
dazonia
and where it was it in london that's
where you know ksi is british
i don't know there's a lot of people
there man yeah dude they have so much
fun so many fans dude i think logan was
there too
to watch
and this i think you guys covered it on
big boy fight news
but so there's a behind the scenes thing
that the leon edwards coaches told him
about the kick how the opening for the
head kick was there yeah so then he's
leaning down he said and this is them
talking about it here yeah i'd love to
see i didn't see this the boys put this
on the fight news already
you see where they moved in yeah yeah if
leo gets that side to deliver the key
that's pretty cool one more ready
so they were planning for that and then
also you can actually hear it here
in this video clip
like right when he says it oh they asked
for it leon listens
one minute later
[Applause]
shocked and sad i know he looked
like he was out of it but yeah he said
head kick and then bone that's dope
yeah apparently uh leonardo was saying
he's never felt worse before he's like i
just felt awful that night mm-hmm
yeah his coaches said that they actually
felt like he was already giving up like
he was done so they had to
[ __ ] for it
they saw me as the enemy who didn't
believe in leon and that wasn't the case
at all
uh dean thomas responds criticism of uc
278 main event come today after calling
leonardo where it's broken ahead of the
fifth round because i will never
apologize for what i said on the
saturday night here's the other thing
these people coming at dean thomas you
know he has like 20 years of
high
level experience not only fighting was a
very good fighter but also coaching in
some of the biggest title fights in ufc
history so when he says i saw on that on
i don't give a [ __ ] fighters i saw this
on his face you should probably listen
the guy knows a thing or two about
fighting if you've never been in there
if you've never coached in a ufc title
fight
shut up
listen to dean thomas and he's like and
just because he pulled off a head kick
doesn't mean he wasn't checked out
at all
yep even his coaches admitted it yeah
yeah
um i think this is also on think we'll
find news so jorge mousev and daniel
cormier they're kind of going back and
forth
because daniel said on the show with rc
dc and rc yeah that why would why should
um leon edwards give mozzarella a chance
at the title when he was like he had the
opportunity before but now that he's
champion now he's going after leon like
so this is what he said exactly
right here so dc said bro don't fight
him cormier said on the dc and rc show
because for two years when he was the
man he could not say your name now the
sudden he's like if you become the champ
he wants to put an end to this thing he
should not fight george mas vidal uh he
literally should just big leak him and
not even say his name because why would
you do that when a guy snuck you
backstage but then never fought you and
all of a sudden you're the man he wants
to fight you
he goes i like george mossville a lot
he's really good dude but it's like come
on george we've got to do better than
that and then
george heard it
um he says guess you're still butthurt
since i didn't do the interview request
on your week youtube channel during my
fight week i know you need my name to
produce some sort of view since ariel
went solo and he became a has been
just make sure when dana calls you you
tells
he tells you to promote the biggest
fight the current champ can
make yeah that's fair uh
which is me wear your best suit from dxl
hilarious make sure you do as you're
told like a good boy maybe get a treat
from your master
then he hashtagged a bunch of
stuff hashtag reason people watch on
mute hashtag fake live coach hashtag
hashtag broke advice
yeah and then cormier responded and then
there's george you've always been the
man
mal uh stay off his page i stand by what
i said you don't get unlimited title
fights malki be uh beat um
uh during yo doreen
which is gilbert burns get to one three
in the last four and maybe get a title
shot see malaki now you get me district
my friend george yeah i doubt that's
george
i remember when england had a champ that
wanted a certain fight and he told the
ufc what he wanted and made it happen
the newbies won't know what i'm talking
about but the real ones do
i'm not sure which one that is uh well
the only champ would be
okay
hmm
i mean yeah i mean
dc is not saying anything that's not
true right yeah i mean i would love to
see muzzled versus leon edwards and also
i said this on last week's shop show if
only on edwards i take that's the fight
i go for it's the biggest i would be
going for a it's the biggest fight
b
it's also listen not an easy fight by
any means but it's easier than camaro
there's a reason camaro's such a big
favorite in the rematch come on
by most
history historians which suggests that
kamal should have won that fir or that
that second fight which we just saw him
get head kick kale you know he's
whatever 56 seconds away from dominating
um you know because that was a very
competitive fight before that
so
you would assume in the rematch if
camaro has [ __ ] together i'm sorry in
the rubber match in the third fight um
if camaro does come in focus he should
just can be very similar
leon edwards team knows that you know
even though he he he had an off night
his body wasn't feeling good so um i
would be all over that miles would all
fight man all over it
all over it
yeah and mozzarella versus
uh leon edwards and they show the
backstage stuff they they you know hype
it up like that's gonna sell pretty
freaking well
and also it's mozzarella man you know
there's some guy that i i know he what
does he say he's won three in his last
four i don't give a [ __ ] put them in
there
mozzarella edwards sell that october get
it done
and then you know tomorrow
and if you're lying on edwards fan
that's what you want because we want
leon elvis make the most money possible
and stay champ the longest possible the
chances of him beating camaro the second
are the third in the three in the rubber
match i keep saying [ __ ] second way
but in the rubber match it's not likely
so
if you're a leon edwards fan you want
him to fight mozville yeah
that's what i want i want mozilla
story i don't give a [ __ ] what is he one
three okay cool i don't get [ __ ] the
climate has changed who cares
yeah like diaz and hamza yeah and then
it's like all right well what do you do
wait around until hop you want you know
homs lightly on edwards even though they
were supposed to fight many times
all right so jake paul announced this on
his twitter he has an opponent
for october
hmm and he said he's going to announce
it i guess like next week by next week
no clue who it is
i mean hopefully it's not that tommy
fury guy just i don't know yeah i guess
i'm over that i know but just to get out
of the way i'm so over that i don't know
what they're gonna do
okay
um this is nate diaz
and apparently this is a guy from usada
that showed up
and then he didn't so nate was supposed
to pee but i guess he didn't give enough
pee
so the homeboy had to wait for him and
then nate was just smoking and getting
this guy to cough around him let me see
[Music]
this man
this man won't get out of my house
because i didn't give him enough pigs
i pissed all i care about
[Music]
how many um do i gotta learn
two more
i got two more liters of piss i gotta
give him and he won't get out of here
until
[Music]
he dk my guy but you sounded like a
[ __ ] second dick
come back in six hours i'll give you two
more
come on leaders middle ladies
sorry dk
why is that
you're just not feeling this
um i mean that's pretty much it but yeah
he did throw that word out
yeah though yeah i don't want to tell
you i know yeah he kind of yeah yeah he
just gets the exemptions i guess from
that some people are going to pass he
did say the n-word yeah it's not even a
headline anyway huh
all right yeah let's see what happens
though yeah cool do your thing man all
right so darren until yourself people
hate usada i know
especially nowadays yeah
uh so darren till announced that he's
going to be coming back um his timeline
is either by december this year or early
like january next year because he's he's
training with comes out for the ds fight
so i guess he's getting in shape
but you know he's been out for a while
since we're a few weeks
do we know what happened to him does he
say so we're a few weeks uh into getting
back homs not fully encamped now for
this fight with diaz so i'm liking camp
how can you help him if you're not
getting back there all right but i'm in
camp for myself to come back the body's
never 100 but i'm coming back what i
used to be like healthy and fit and
ready to get a world title and get some
wins in mass fight against one of the
best dragons division so this is all
just about getting back now i won't have
fights within this year just boom boom
the next year's a big year the comeback
is on i'm rooting for him man yeah
hopefully yeah good stuff he's a fun one
just hope he gets [ __ ] together yeah
we'll see
all right so this is uh
bisbee had a documentary that came out a
lot of people say it's a good
documentary yeah it's great amazing
documentary and so the ufc is now
suing their production team because they
use copyright you know written footage
obviously right ufc is the only league
like this like if you use any
they're easing off a little bit but like
if you think the nfl nba whatever it is
on on social media and use a clip the
ufc will pull it down with a heartbeat
you know the only league like that
it's like get it out there man i know i
don't agree with it at all but also
for bisping it's like uh
man the amount of [ __ ] the sacrifice he
has one eye you son of a [ __ ] he has
one [ __ ] eye
because you had him [ __ ] it was it who
who did that belford did you know about
foreign trt you know exactly what you're
doing and it's like the amount of
sacrifice you made for the ufc you won't
let this great documentary use some
footage
yeah
so ufc complaint drafted by attorneys
um in santa monica clinton do you see
only one of the documents because bisbee
himself reached out to producer
contacted ufc the uc employee in turn
encouraged bisbeem to have a score which
is a company contract ufc
discuss licensing that contact never
occurred
yeah so they use like a ton of footage
yeah but there's also the whole well the
reason why the ufc is also upset i guess
they use the conor mcgregor versus jose
aldo footage which is like
it's not bisping in there but you know
what they were thinking i mean they're
doing you're wrong
it's since it's bizbeing i bet they're
like yeah we're fine we should just run
it by it yeah
uh ufc's uh so the extent of
intellectual property borrowing and
bisbeing is astounding there are 24
copyright works spread out over 160
clips of the scenes amount to about 19
minutes of the movie's run time of 109
minutes nearly a fifth of the film
directly relies on ufc copyright works
god and it's not just bisping yeah but
they're insane or the production team is
saying it's like you know it's like fair
use stuff if i'm going to talk about
something
you know
and also bisping is an executive
producer so i wonder if he's going to be
sued as well because they're you know
they're suing the production team make
matters
making matters worse ufc contends
business borrows substantial portions of
the ufc's most famous fights conor
mcgregor defeat jose aldo dan heston
knocked out business that makes sense
yeah why wouldn't you let him get
knocked out
but yeah we'll see what happens with
this well i'll tell you what happens
they're [ __ ] yeah
yeah
but how i mean that's a big production
yeah i mean nobody ran it by the ufc i
know i don't know
that's tough
i mean hopefully the ufc is like gets
busy let's be cool dude he has one eye
because of what he did production
company
he has one [ __ ] eye because he
sacrificed his body for you for the ufc
let him ride yeah out of anybody come on
man and people
enjoy the dock i'm sure they want to go
see more ufc stuff after watching the
doctor yeah hell yeah yeah only builds
the ufc yeah
and he works for the ufc i know he
currently works for you
ah we'll see
so this was pretty crazy mark zuckerberg
was actually on joe rogan's podcast
right yeah and then they were talking
about jiu jitsu i guess zuckerberg is a
i think he's a black belt in jiu-jitsu i
think i'm not here for sure he's saying
black belt i think i don't know
but um they did say that um tom hardy
and mario lopez you know mario very well
yes uh they're
like they're competing now and then they
both won golds i think in certain
competitions okay and they're like the
masters division blue belt levels blue
belt yeah yeah i saw tom hardy i saw a
picture of him just competing yeah just
him actually getting an armbar on
somebody
imagine signing up for a juicy
tournament and competing against bane
you know tom hardy's not a big guy
though no yeah doesn't seem to like it
um i'll just play right it's tim get
armbar right
oh yes nice tone
it's cool he's doing it proper in a ghee
too that's what i respect
[Music]
that's pretty cool
cool indeed so him and mario lopez now
training jiu-jitsu together no not
together but
two celebrities obviously tom is quite a
bigger celebrity but yeah two
celebrities yeah
that's dope yeah
um
oh there's talk i guess there's rumors
that they might actually please don't
please don't please just do your thing
under the radar compete please don't
do you have to do this i highly doubt
tom hardy signs up for that
tomorrow he's like what
mario's like let's do it guaranteed
smiling mario's like let's do it and i
do just [ __ ] just do it under the
radar do your thing
so mario said he started competing
because his son
is in the jiu jitsu yep i get it yeah my
kid was in jutsu made me give my go and
literally fly to denver and pick up my
black belt i haven't for years i didn't
give a [ __ ]
you should definitely get it though have
them
but wait mark zuckerberg was saying uh
he didn't compete right i don't think he
competes but i think that would get me
back into competition i would
love to compete against mark zuckerberg
let's see what it says here
hooked on jiu jitsu
mma now
where has it been all my life
i don't did you listen to any of that
podcast at all no i had to listen to i
thought they're gonna be like to dive
into like you know crazier stuff but it
just started off with him talking about
v you know virtual reality and stuff
like that that's joe yeah he's joe's not
like a gotcha yeah but he did ask him
some stuff so yeah the biden i saw the
clips of the bite and stuff yeah um
let's see romans so how did you
initially approach it like how did you
get a trainer what do you do a bunch of
people who are into it there's actually
this really interesting connection
between people surf and do jiu jitsu oh
really uh oh yeah so so
wait mark's like we're saying yeah so so
so so a bunch of guys
so he might maybe he's not a robot talks
like me uh so a bunch of guys who i do
that with you know they're kind of have
gyms and kawaii you know
i basically collect a bunch of
recommendations ran them by a bunch of
people who i know and i'm gonna train
with this guy dave camarillo yeah he's a
monster
he's great uh super nice guy i feel like
i'm wearing a ton christine's like i
don't know man i mean it's just really
the best sport
i don't like i don't the question isn't
how did i get into it it's how did i not
know about it
until just now from like
yeah this is impossible to [ __ ]
navigate through who this
he he can't talk this way this has to be
the transcription
he does stumble on stuff really like
elon musk too he does the same thing
kind of like stumbles like him a little
bit a little bit you never know the
[ __ ] are so so smart though heavy
lies the ground though
um
uh
where's it been my whole life i'm sorry
i'm curious if this was preconceived
before i went on rogan
like hey i'm into jitsu i get my black
belt i remember i'm the one that guessed
that billion dollars probably not what
belt
is mark
i mean for a bird
i mean if he was there
let's scratch the black belt i heard
black belt somewhere
he probably owns black belts
but not like why did you black belt
i'd be
shocked if he was a black belt and he
just said how did i just find this in my
life
yeah minimum 10 years get a black belt
okay so i remember he said something
about how surfing that's how he kind of
gets his you know
peace and whatever harmony so
since he can't go surfing all the time
it's easier to go to jiu jitsu and you
can still get that whatever it is yeah
surf and juicy go together like peanut
butter and jelly baby
all right this is an update with king
velazquez
um so there's going to be another
hearing
and he says there's going to be some
surprises like the this guy and his
family piece of [ __ ] yeah total pieces
of crap i'll just show you this real
quick look forward to seeing how they
plan on proving the case when one of the
witnesses they're not going to call the
two have invoked the fifth amendment and
they're not saying anything oh wow
i like to know if they're going to weigh
that and get on the stand subject
themselves to cross-examination i hope
they do yep investigation i was revealed
that it's apparent that the mother and
stepfather were
oh my god involved in everything it was
going on a day going on at the daycare
center we've got a lot of questions for
them stay tuned we'll see you next month
and we and we think there's going to be
some surprises and then it goes on here
my client wants to tell people his story
i'll just leave it at that he wants to
tell them the truth he wants the truth
to come out as i do that's why i said
that it's upside down world usually when
you're in the defense the last thing you
want to do is anything but to try your
case but within the prosecution case
here in this case quitting case i think
when the truth comes out people are
going to be even more horrified than i
already are
crazy more horrified than they already
are dude
yeah
so aggravating
okay all right some fight announcements
chris dawkiss and charzinha rosenstra
that's a fun one
dacas
philly's finest cops yep
and this was interesting too vitor
belfort versus who jake paul should have
fought hassim ramon jr
that is an interesting one october
because if it is if it's vitor and he's
allowed to do whatever he wants dude
hassan roman jr is in for a surprise
vitor can box his ass off and he's
[ __ ] quick
hmm
let's go to vitor's instagram real quick
because i think he does look
isn't he using filters or some [ __ ]
let's see
oh
go to that one the far right one yeah it
does look like he's or botox or
something
yeah he does look
is that a filter is that can't face
i think his face looks a lot smoother
his wife's still doing the damage
how about his son
he's fighting super baller oh baller
yeah like one of the best quarterbacks
in the nation yeah vitor's looking
jacked
interesting
what's that in the zone some [ __ ]
yeah just zone okay that makes sense
that sounds kind of trippy too on the
zone
um this one i thought was interesting so
dan hooker he's going to be finding a
guy named claudio poyle's yeah 45 was
just too much man
and that's claudio's record so doing the
damn thing
yeah
and this one too kevin holland versus
daniel rodriguez
such a [ __ ] fight that should be a
banger now i wanted kevin holland versus
tony ferguson
damn
i thought that had been a fun one
and you know daniel yeah i'll take
daniel rodriguez all day that's such a
fun [ __ ] fight i figured for holland
though his camp would want
um
that
scalp of ferguson
the fight that was another one too so
tony ferguson versus li jinglang
did we already talk about that last week
though i don't know
yeah we did okay
jill son says not trying to be a dick
but doesn't see a point of tony first
first lee jayling fight why
let's see um i don't like it you want to
talk about charles lavere you don't want
to talk about what a big star is they
say that him versus gateshead was the
biggest player for the year not to
mention this had the heavyweight fight
between
undisputed interim still telling me that
all oliver geisha was number one albert
does doesn't exist that belt doesn't
exist and story doesn't exist tony
fursten who was up in the loft had not
dropped the ladder down so that all
oliveira could climb up it was he
tomorrow he lost a bunch of fights
now we're going to bring first him back
great
great story he's hanging in there he's
traded camps he's at jackson's now he's
doing things different and you're giving
him i don't know a leech
i don't know if that's his
nickname or his name i'm not trying to
be a dick i assume you call a guy leech
he claims we haven't the foggiest idea
who we've got opposite of towing
prisoner how are we supposed to pretend
that wow he acts like he doesn't know
who he's hating on jingling leech
if leech wins what happens what's the
end of the road for tony yeah jail it's
a tough [ __ ] fight for tony very
tough fight jaguar's fantastic fighter
all right where'd chris fighting this
weekend but he said that he eventually
wants to move up to 205 pounds and stay
there i like that
i love him at 205. that's why i said
remember after he lost last time so i
said he should do his whole team should
go to 205.
i've been thinking about 205 for a fair
bit the problem is i wouldn't go to 205
and come back down
um
you see a lot of guys that try that and
they just get starched and they come
back down to make sense yeah i love them
at 205.
all righty
uh paul acosta underwent him or
yeah i wonder what hand surgery i guess
he broke his hand during the fight he's
out for a hot second then broke my hand
the fight without a bone injury or maybe
ligaments but what really happened was
the fractured
hoped it wasn't fractured then i would
be able to come back 50 60 days
plan on fighting six days won't be
possible i have to fight i'll have to
fight in december if you're lucky or
january
yeah a hot second
and dustin poirier just tweeted out msg
oh you know it's against chandler so
then yeah apparently so this guy
commented uh kaposa so ufc msg tickets
went on public today noporia chandler
announcement then he goes on fighting
november 12th
hmm
i have to text chandler yeah
it's a great fight though
john jones posted this
total of thirteen fights things yep for
john goes 14 time to fight wins in the
fc yeah yeah there's no comparison at
all i know
it didn't make sense
i mean now
khabib definitely could have been the
greatest of all time you know he's maybe
lost one round against connor but on
that he's dominated every single
time but again john's point
i got more title fight wins than you
have told a win son it's a it's a
terrible argument it'd be tough to argue
that
yeah the only thing would be the whole
pd's yeah that's it
i don't care about that i know you don't
so we already knew this is happening
because
luke basically said he's gonna retire
but you know he didn't put his gloves in
the octagon so they thought maybe
there's a chance but he did notify ufc
of his retirement good for him yeah
jail that had a funny thing he was like
he goes i don't want uh rock hole to
retire he's like i wanna see him fight
more now than ever after that last fight
yeah
if he was like that all the time it'd be
fine crazy
i mean you're not going to be a world
title guy but yeah but it's fun
but you don't want to take that abuse no
that's not what you want to do i'm good
for luke and that time off was great
because he took some hard hits and he
stayed in there yep
uh this is just a
i'm looking at justin wren he's looking
like he's in crazy shape right now yeah
he does look good
good for him man yeah
i would play this but there's music
behind it yeah about he does freaking
biceps yeah jacked yeah
all right let's go
i just please
will blackman i love will i used to work
with will oh
how tall should be when the hibachi chef
sets the grill on fire they do freak the
[ __ ] out
that's hilarious
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know my kids freak out we had a
half-assed one at [ __ ] betty house
last time went though he didn't do the
the volcano out of the onions or nothing
really i was like come on dude let's go
where's the lights
he's like here here's a [ __ ] shrimp
did he at least throw in your mouth
no i mean he threw it in his hat okay
like the eggs like you put up and then
spin it around but i'm like dude get the
lights out in the smoke and all that
yeah the volcano isn't one of those yeah
he's in a bad day
he did an off day
so this okay
they said he had a hero's welcome
and i looked at the footage it's kind of
like there's not that many people showed
up for uh leon edwards when he came with
them
[Music]
yeah
i mean when we were compared to like
remember yuri prahashka yeah i know it's
just different like london london has a
lot of [ __ ] popping you know a lot of
[ __ ] going on stuff happening that day
yeah
a real quick one bj penn
i know you're
all over this yep he's officially
contesting the governor primary election
results because you know he didn't win
yeah he's saying that they did a
government or sorry voter suppression
they talked about him bad in the media
and this and that so he's contesting it
well we'll see what happens with that
yeah
he's trying to get that race track up
there
do we know that we don't have that
racetrack we need a racetrack that's so
funny
uh this is just a beat magametripov um
talking about the retirement oh
interesting so he says mostly because he
didn't get like the ufc would promise
one thing but not deliver so that was
the main reason why he retired oh well
that was the main reason why i got mad i
thought it was because i mean i think
let's be honest the main reason is
because he you know he had some health
problems then also he has a
better option yeah like he's an actual
career now mm-hmm
and he's not gonna get hit
so
over the weekend john dodson had his uh
bkfc debut and he won
knock the dude finish uh there's a quick
highlight
first round yep
you knocked him three times down damn
yeah this is the third one
yeah dawson's quick two man reaching in
round one 45 seconds remaining in the
first
right hand left hand we might be done
and we are a massive win for john jesus
christ yeah he's fun to watch a great
debut yep
i love john dawson this is pretty nasty
this is from kaposa
i will just play it for you
[Music]
was one of them
and that ref still didn't know till it
was snapped just had a bad angle
yeah that was bruised
how
the ref come on dude you gotta get in
there man
yeah
is that it brother i think that's it um
oh so there's another fight this weekend
as well outside the ufc ruiz ortiz oh
it's a fun one
on sunday yeah watch the [ __ ] out of
that
nine nine pm eastern
andrew ruiz louis ortiz it's a fun one
yeah
but of course this is the main one and
then at noon
might be doing a fight campaigning for
it old school style too with rogan cyril
gone taito taitovasa robert whittaker
mundatory roman
coppolav nazarot it's a fun card man and
that's noon pacific
uh for you
hardcores out there but that's in france
paris to be exact
is that it brother that's it all right
back on tour for your boy uh this
wednesday 8pm show at the hollywood
improv shop and friends i have david
spade rappaport some other big ass names
all coming together one night one show
only 8 p.m
spade rapport
some very special guests i can't wait
for this one that's one show only at 8
p.m in hollywood and then uh the real
tour starts in appleton wisconsin
september september's busy man so get
your tickets now appleton wisconsin that
[ __ ] almost sold out appleton wisconsin
september 8th through the 10th and then
ontario california ontario improv my
phase ontario improv is september 15th
through 17th and then i end september in
boston laugh boston september 29th
through october 1st uh they just added
for october san jose and salt lake city
so get your tickets right now at
fatkz.com or stickboy.com think where
you can get the tiger thick whiskey you
can also get the new merch that just
dropped and play commercial now boys
um you're good
we have the nba quality uh jerseys
basketball jerseys and shorts and the
hat you see me rocking right now is also
just dropped on there as well um and the
the trucker hat that was
only available in person is now
available online the thick boy trucker
hat thick boy tie-dye it's all there
jerseys tie-dyes all the merch the hats
the trucker hats the thick boy fight
club gringo poppy all that stuff you can
get it right now um thickboy.com all
right kids that's it but hollywood
improv wednesday night david spade
rapport some other monsters appleton
ontario boston get your
ticketstickboy.com stay thick be nice to
each other i'm out